you're Canadian on top of everything
else oh my goodness
yeah no no I haven't lived in a long
time
so you abandoned your country Canada it
needs to be a uprising why your people
running away why we try to write to you
guys you know what I'm going back on
Sunday
can I go with are you using myself that
if I might use you for health benefits
I've got a cow through every interview
that we do I'm learning him more and
more I'm starting to fall in love it
feels like totally real peace every
single so that's interesting to explore
Tiffany do you flirt with all the
Canadian guys who have health benefits
to health plan well Miss hatty certainly
knows how to turn it on especially as
she takes on her first major voiceover
role in the new lego movie why wouldn't
you want to marry me just you know again
purely for curiosity sake
oh god forgot like you it's been an
honor and a privilege to be a part of a
franchise you know this big and to be
able to get free toolings
like these and it's cool because you
know like he only has one version of
himself so many version no they gave me
one too it's cool it doesn't look as
much like me but I could change my form
to something else if this makes you
uncomfortable
hey guys leave it or not before these
two stepped into Legoland
they had other life goals when I was
like nine ten eleven I wanted to play
for the Toronto Maple Leafs I want to be
a hockey player I want to be a goalie I
wanted to work in a beef jerky factory
or the liquor factory or a pantyhose
Factory or I want to be a horse farmer
because my crime I said it and do what
you love if you do what you love you
never work a day you like what you love
is factories right and then what I found
out I found out later is if I become a
comedian or an actress I could
potentially do all those things and get
paid more money than if I actually did
those things so now my beef jerky movies
coming out real soon
[Music]